today on the matt walsh show new york
magazine published a celebratory profile
about a woman who violently mutilated
her own body and the story only gets
worse from there also joe biden
addresses the nation about the threat of
the extremely mild omnicorn variant bill
gates moves the goal posts on vaccines
and hopes that nobody notices and the
woman who created sex in the city has
regrets about her lifestyle choices
and then apparently regrets expressing
those regrets and a lutheran pastor
delivers a homily in drag and then in
our daily cancellation we will ask and
answer an important question
what are the worst christmas songs and
movies the answers may surprise you all
of that and more today on the matt walsh
show
[Music]
well you might think that the holiday
season is a time of giving but you know
it's also a time of taking for cyber
criminals looking to cash in some tips
to help you stay safe while holiday
shopping include only visiting secure
sites and apps from retailers you trust
using a vpn instead of public wi-fi
creating strong passwords and checking
your bank and credit accounts for fraud
because every day we put our information
at risk on the internet in an instant a
cyber criminal could steal what's yours
sometimes even harm your finances your
credit or even your reputation good
thing there's life lock lifelock helps
detect a wide range of identity threats
um things that you might not be able to
check on your own or you might not even
think about on your own like if your
social security number is for sale on
the dark web if they detect your
information that has been potentially
compromised they'll send you an alert
and um if god forbid something does
happen they have dedicated restoration
specialists that will help you if you
become a victim nobody can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can help protect what's yours with
lifelock by norton join now and save up
to 25 off your first year by going to
lifelock.com welsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off
so take my hand now and follow me down
this rabbit hole it's going to take us
to some dark and horrifying places but
there are lessons to be learned along
the way
and we begin in the present day with a
journalist who now goes by the name
gabrielle mack
and identifies as a man though she is a
biological female
gabrielle is featured on the cover of
the latest issue of new york magazine in
a story which she penned herself titled
my penis myself
i didn't need a penis to be a man we're
told on the cover but i needed one to be
myself
now the article goes into graphic gory
detail about gabriel gabrielle's quest
to surgically masculinize herself in
order to vaguely approximate the
appearance of a biological male i'll
i'll read only as much of the piece as
is needed to get the point across
i will tell you that the first line is
this
on the day that i heard my penis would
be huge i sobbed
that's the first line
yes i mean what man cannot relate to
that experience
you know you're actually a man if you
select your penis out of a catalog
rather than simply you know being born
with one
the article goes from there and it gets
more bizarre and certainly a lot more
nauseating here's a few morsels and i'm
kind of choosing bits somewhat at random
but um but here they are at one point
she says
i could not have gotten my boobs cut off
fast enough and i spent weeks before my
2019 hysterectomy up late in bed hot and
sleepless fantasizing about the moment
the medical waste disposal team at uc
san francisco would batch incinerate my
uterus which swirled with dysphoria like
nausea from the depths of my soul
just as you might feel an automatic no
if a doctor offered to cut one of your
healthy arms off for you when i thought
about cauterizing excising and sewing
closed my vagina my whole body cringed
wrong
well yeah that that is certainly wrong
at another point we're told
the whole process is constant body
horror
baryan a nurse said at one point
after he told me that the penis tip
discoloration i was worried about might
just be tissue that's dying off which is
also fine and this was a recovery with
no complications that required surgery
the overall proportion of
phallophalloplasties that's uh what they
call the surgery where they make a fake
penis that needs surgical revision while
lower for some surgeons including mine
is about one in two
the highest number of corrective
follow-up surges surgeries needed by
anyone i know personally is 12.
so did you get that one in two of these
surgeries has to be corrected and there
are people who have 12
corrective surgeries well that's totally
normal right 12 corrective surgeries
she also talks about the controversy
over this procedure even within the
trans community
she says phalloplasty in general it was
clear it was hard for people to accept
well i will love you no matter what
sweetie a cis female best friend of mine
said when i told her i was transitioning
years before
quote as long as you don't get it
one flatly demanded don't get it
it was another trans masculine person i
used to know said disgusting insane to
want and to have a surgeon make a a
sensate phallus out of your arm or leg
or somewhere and frankenstitch it to
your body to go so far out of your way
to opt into a tool perhaps the tool of
so much suffering
is wrong she said
most transmasculine people didn't get
one
the seminole print trans mask magazine
was named after not getting one it's
called original plumbing i saw trans
masculine support groups shut down and
go silent more than once when someone
brought up the procedure and later when
i was that someone i was twice invited
to leave with other people who might
want to talk about that
now so she doesn't hide from the fact
that this procedure
is
dangerous where they make a fake penis
and they stitch it to your body in fact
the procedure kills people
but that also seems to be a potential
perk from her perspective
she says it has happened at least once
that someone did die from the procedure
i was fully ready to by which i mean i
just spent nearly the last of my savings
which i'd burn navigating the uh social
medical legal extreme mind
f
show of transitioning on a burial plot
just in case
so she bought herself a burial plot
before the procedure again
totally normal
one of the nodding heads in the group
belonged to a non-binary white person
who was still horizontal in recovery
from having had a week prior the worst
happen which was that after their
procedure in which all the fat and skin
had been stripped from their left
forearm from wrist to nearly elbow along
with major nerves and artery and veins
and then shaped into a tube and
connected in careful layers to skin and
blood vessels and nerves in their pelvis
their new penis had failed
it died on them but here they were
already getting ready for their surgeons
to harvest a whole other part of their
body within a month with zero hesitation
because those three those three days
they'd had their penis they said before
being rushed into an eight-hour surgery
that couldn't save it the feeling of it
even just for one moment
even still bloody and painful and packed
with stitches
made it all worth it
now if this all sounds totally insane um
then get a load of this line
she says but when penis is self as penis
is a gift to self
it's a gift too to others
my penis is a gift to others she says
there's a
interesting pick up line i guess you
could try
and yet penis itself is the more
revealing phrase here because she sees
the self as being contained within a sex
organ penis is self
that might be if i if i had to pick any
three words to sum up
the leftist ideology it might be that
yourself is contained by your sex organs
or in this case an artificial sex organ
a sex organ constructed from flesh
hacked off of your own body
now this is probably a good time to show
you the picture if you haven't seen this
if there could possibly be a good time
for that here's the cover of the
magazine um with a gabrielle mac and you
see
her in her underwear
with a huge hole dug out of her thigh
there you can see that in the in the
thigh but you also notice something else
the sad thing here if we can select just
one sad thing from this tragic
grotesque spectacle
and and that is that she still doesn't
look at all like a man
right she has wide hips kind of an
hourglass figure
she's very small and petite
now she doesn't look like a woman
certainly but neither does she look like
a man
she's in sort of a gender purgatory
what we find is is that we can reject
the gift of our own physical selves by
mutilating our bodies
but what we cannot do is create a new
self
you know when it comes to ourselves
we have only the power to maintain or
destroy not to create
if you if you choose to destroy yourself
you'll be left with this
which is what all trans people who get
surgeries are left with
you're left living in a prison of your
own making
stuck like that forever
but i told you this story gets darker
and it does
gabrielle mack has extensive experience
doing violence to herself in fact back
in 2011 when she was still a journalist
named mac mcclelland and still
identified as a woman
she wrote an article for good magazine
where she describes staging her own
violent rape
now mcclellan wrote at the time that she
met a woman in haiti when she was in
haiti uh you know
i think she was working for mother jones
and she was a journalist in haiti
station there
and um a year prior to this so 2010 she
was in haiti and she met a woman who had
been gang raped by a group of men
now this experience meeting this woman
supposedly caused trauma for her for
mcclelland
she was the one who had the trauma and
after talking over with her therapist as
she explains in this article she wrote
the two decided that the best way to
overcome this trauma would be to stage
her own rape
and so she enlisted a helpful friend to
have violent sex with her while
suffocating and beating her
and and she went through it then she
says the experience was cathartic and
healing
now
what this tells us first and foremost is
that mcclelland is a deeply disturbed
mentally ill person
and we would have known that even
without her background of
therapeutically raping herself but that
detail drives the point home i think
but then again i think i think mentally
ill is kind of too broad a category to
be useful here
more specifically we should say that
that mcclellan suffers from a very
potent and very toxic mix of psychotic
narcissism and self-loathing
and those two things not only can go
hand in hand but almost always do
she's a narcissist because she's totally
obsessed with herself
she can't think about anything but
herself
that's all she thinks about all she
writes about
a woman in haiti was gang-raped
and somehow that became a story about
her
and her own trauma
she fetishized someone else's rape and
then wrote about it proudly in a
magazine
this is such a perfectly narcissistic
move that it ought to be included as an
example of the word in the dictionary
but she also hates herself that's why
she wanted to be beaten and brutalized
she's turned on by the idea of someone
abusing her because she despises her
herself
she says that the fake rape was a
successful form of therapy
and and she was healed from the
experience not surprisingly that turns
out to be untrue
because she spiraled from there spitting
around in circles of self-loathing and
narcissism until she committed the
ultimate act of self-hating narcissism
by mutilating her body and attempting to
construct a brand new self
out of the pieces
you know constructing a self out of the
pieces of the old self like her body was
nothing but a box of legos or a potato
head doll
she sees the self not as a complete and
coherent thing but as fragmentary
a collection of arbitrary parts each
meaningless in its own right adding up
to a whole which is also meaningless
of course there's a very serious logical
problem with all of this i mean many
logical problems but here's one
we're told that gender is meaningless
anyway
we're told that penises have nothing at
all to do with manhood
we're told that a penis isn't is only
arbitrarily associated with being a man
it has no actual bearing on the matter
so
what's the point of the operation
isn't getting a penis in that case like
getting a beak or feathers or having a
three additional fingers attached to
your left hand
it's a totally random and unnecessary
bodily addition which has no inherent
meaning whatsoever
that's what gender theory tells us
and yet gender theory also propels women
to chop off their breasts and have fake
penises attached to their crotches in an
effort to be men it's totally confused
and that's by design
can any thinking human look at this
disturbed person
and listen to her story
and conclude that sex change surgery is
what she needed
should it not be clear that her sickness
is in the mind not the body
isn't that obvious for everyone who
seeks out these kinds of procedures
it is of course but the argument starts
to feel futile when you realize
that the people pushing this kind of
frankenstein butchery
aren't making any sincere attempt to
help the mentally afflicted people who
seek it out
they aren't worried about the logical
problems much less the moral problems
it is in the end all about destruction
so when i sit here and say this is
destruction what they say is well yeah
thanks for noticing
destruction of the so-called gender
binary
destruction of truth
of science
destruction of beauty
destruction of society of civilization
and it all begins
at the most fundamental level
with the destruction of the self
which is what we have here
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i'm not one to keep up on the trends
you've probably noticed that especially
celebrity trends but recently i have
learned about an under under the radar
investment that some of the ultra
wealthy have been quietly funneling
their money into for generations
and it really piqued my interest famous
folks are known for touting their art
collection but you no longer have to be
a coastal elite to invest in one of the
oldest asset classes of all time because
masterworks is making adding art to your
portfolio portfolio possible masterworks
gives investors just like you access to
the asset class that had low correlation
to the s p 500 over the past two decades
masterworks even achieved a 32 and 31
net return for investors based on the
sale of a banksy and condo piece in 2020
and 2021 respectively now you don't have
to be a hedge fund manager to invest in
multi-million dollar paintings from
iconic artists like picasso warhol and
banksy and even better masterworks is
giving my listeners priority access to
their latest offerings simply go to
masterworks dot i o slash walsh to get
started that's masterworks dot io slash
walsh before deciding to invest
carefully review the important
disclosures at masterworks dot io
disclaimer
so we're going through a little bit of a
tough time at home um
my wife took our two-year-old daughter
to get her first haircut
yesterday and she ended up with a mullet
like a full-on
i mean full-on mullet is what she ended
up with which is to be expected i guess
when you take a two-year-old girl to
sports clips
and apparently my wife told me you know
when i when i saw the haircut she said
they were giving out free cuts at sports
clips
so like for free there's a reason why i
mean you get what you pay for right
and i think that's i think that's true
not always in life but in certain areas
and um it's it's true definitely with
haircuts and hotel rooms those are like
maybe the two areas where you you get
what you pay for
and and she told me that i'm like that's
something i would do
bring the girls for a free haircut at
sports clips
and so this is what we end up with they
just they mulleted her without asking um
and i found out when my wife sent a
picture of our daughter to a group text
with her sister and her mom and my
brother-in-law
and my wife was pretty devastated by it
and all i did was send joe dirt gifts
because that's what she looks like
i don't know what else to do
we're picking up the pieces now and
moving on
with a daughter who looks like
the tiger king
nothing you could do now i mean you
could shave it all off go with the buzz
cut i'm not sure
although i am told that that that i
guess mullets are in now i mean it's a
trendy thing i guess that's why they
assumed it sports clips that that's what
you want
um all right we'll start with this biden
gave his a speech about omnicorn
yesterday and uh let's tune in and watch
a little bit of that
and again to folks who are not
vaccinated you might think you're
putting only yourself at risk
but it's your choice
your choice is not just a choice about
you
affects other people
you're putting other people at risk
your loved ones your friends neighbors
strangers you run into
and your choice can be the difference
between life or death
the longer the virus is around
the more likely variants form
that may be deadlier than the ones that
have come before
let me say again and again and again and
again
please get vaccinated
it's the only responsible thing to do
those who are not vaccinated or causing
hospitals to over run become overrun
again
i just spoke to the governor of new york
every covet 19 hospital means someone
with a heart attack cancer other serious
illness may not get that bed and that
life-saving care they need in the
hospital
look let me give it to you straight
again
omicron is serious potentially deadly
business for unvaccinated people
okay uh first of all where to even begin
we we heard from the ceo of uh that runs
the
the the um
organization which which runs
like dozens of hospitals in new york
yesterday and uh and he said that they
they're they're at like 10 capacity with
hotel with uh with hospitals rather
it's it's not a problem everything's
fine as far as hospital capacity goes
so that's a lie from
from biden but then we have this as he
says he's well i'm gonna shoot it to you
straight again it's like he's shooting
it straight and uh but they say a
different thing every day
and
so
again we run into this problem
where they say where he says
get get the vaccine because uh that's
going to protect other people
and if if it's protecting other people
then that means right
that uh that supposedly that the vaccine
is stopping the spread of the virus
if it's about protecting other people
and yet if it stops the spread of the
virus and it stops you from contracting
the virus
then why do you have to worry about
protecting people who already vaccinated
why do why is it my job to protect a
vaccinated person
that's what the vaccine is supposed to
do
if it actually stops the spread of the
virus
but then again if it doesn't stop the
spread of the virus
then getting a vaccine
makes almost no difference in terms of
protecting other people
because whether you're vaccinated or not
you're still spreading it
they still they they cannot be honest
about it
and just say listen
if you're in a high-risk group
especially
here's what the vaccine will do for you
it's not going to stop the spread but it
might make the the illness less severe
that's what it's going to do
but yeah you know you could spread it
whether whether you're vaccinated or not
but fortunately omnicorn is a is is very
mild and is is a cold that's that's
basically what it is for most people for
all intents and purposes
they can't say that but they are they
are starting to shift the goal posts a
little bit so here's bill gates with a
uh
a thread on twitter yesterday
talking about omnicord and he says uh
just when it seemed like life would
return to normal we could be entering
the worst part of the pandemic now he
claims omnicorn will hit a hit home for
all of us close friends of mine now have
it and i've canceled most of my holiday
plans i bet you have omnicorn is
spreading faster than any virus in
history it will soon be in every country
in the world
the big unknown is how sick omnicorn
makes you we need to take it seriously
until we know more about it even if it's
only half as severe as delta it will be
the worst surge we have seen so far
because it's so infectious in the
meantime we all have to look out for
each other especially the most
vulnerable whether they live down the
street or in another country that means
wearing masks avoiding big indoor
gatherings and getting vaccinated
getting a booster gives the best
protection and then here's this
there will be more breakthrough cases in
people who are vexed which sounds
concerning but it's purely a factor of
how many people are vacs and how fast
this variant is spreading vaccines are
designed
to prevent people from getting seriously
ill or dying and are doing that well
okay that's that is a a straight-up lie
that's not why the vaccines were
designed
um they were not they were not
specifically designed to prevent people
from getting seriously ill they were
designed and they were sold as
preventing people from getting sick
that's that's what they were designed to
do that's how they were sold originally
that's how people like bill gates sold
them
that's why we call that's why
you know early on and he uses the phrase
here again but we haven't heard it quite
as often recently but early on
especially when we heard about people
still getting sick with the vaccine they
called it a breakthrough case
bill gates wants to hang on to that
language but you know you don't hear
that phrase
very often anymore
because everyone's contracting it
whether they're vexed or not
so this is a giant shift of the goal
posts and uh again we're supposed to not
notice
oh the vaccine's all along all they were
meant to do was just prevent prevent a
serious illness
which they do prevent serious illness so
you could you could say that
you could say the vaccines prevent
serious illness okay
great
but to try to pretend that that was
merely solely the point
and the design of the vaccines from the
beginning
is not true
but they can't be honest they'll never
be honest
mayor lightfoot in chicago is the latest
democrat mayor to institute segregation
policies
and uh here's what she says
uh we didn't want it to get to this
point but given the situation we find
ourselves in we have no choice beginning
january 3rd you must show proof you're
fully vaxxed to enter bars restaurants
fitness centers and entertainment
recreational venues where food and drink
are served
then she says to put it simply if you've
been living vaccine-free
your time is up
if you wish to live uh life as with the
ease to do things you love you must be
vast this health order may pose an
inconvenience to the unvaccinated and in
fact it is inconvenient by design
yet again a little bit of a little bit
of honesty pokes through
you know you got to wade through a whole
bunch of bs to get to the little little
glimmers of honesty and uh and we get
something here we get a little bit of
honesty here where she says
that's that's what this is really about
it's about inconveniencing
unvaccinated people and she's right
about that but not so much
inconveniencing
being excluded from all aspects of
society
being told that you cannot publicly
participate in society that's a lot more
than an inconvenience
i mean just think about how the left
reacted
when one gay couple in one town in
colorado were not able to get one type
of cake from one bakery
was that was that a mere inconvenience
no this was in fact the phrases that
they were this was exclusion from
society they weren't able to participate
in society it was oppression
persecution
we need a supreme court case about it
because one gay couple couldn't get one
type of cake from one little bakery in
one town in colorado
there were like 50 other bakeries they
could have gone to within a 10 mile
radius and got in everything they wanted
and in fact within that one bakery they
could have gotten any cake they wanted
they just couldn't get that
they were not able to get a custom cake
for this particular event which was a
gay wedding
i don't think lori lightfoot
if she chimed in on that was gonna call
that an inconvenience
no that is exclusion from society if
you're a gay couple and yet
being told that not only can you not get
a cake from the bakery you can't even
walk into any bakery in the city and you
also can't walk into any other place in
the city
that's a mere inconvenience right
so that's not the honest part um the
honest part is is at least that she's
admitting
in so many words that this isn't
actually about keeping people safe
it is about punishing unvaccinated
people
unvaccinated people are not complying
and uh that is that is very distressing
and
infuriating
to
emperor lightfoot lightfoot
and her fellow despots and so they're
going to punish you for it
that's what it's all about all right
let's go to a different mayor this is
incoming new york mayor eric adams he
gave a press conference yesterday and
defended his position on putting inmates
in solitary confinement so people on the
left have been going after him for this
um
because he is actually
despite being a democrat basically a law
and order democrat there are very few of
them that exist anymore
uh he is one
and here he is um
addressing that
and the the democrats in the left they
they don't really like what he had to
say here we'll talk about that in a
minute let's let's listen
for people to continue to say every
support solitary confinement that is
just a lie
i support punitive segregation i am not
going to be in a city
where dangerous people assault innocent
people
go to jail and assault more people
you cannot have a jail system where
someone sexually assault a staffer
slash
a an inmate
and then say it is all right i'm going
to give you an ipad and just hug you and
say don't do it again no
if you are violent you must be removed
from population so that you don't in
inflate violence on other people that's
clear if you want to work as a partner
call me hear my my understandings and my
belief the one thing that's different
from everyone that signed a letter and
eric adams i wore bulletproof vests for
22 years and protected the people of the
city and when you do that then you have
the right to question me on safety and
public safety matters i think i know a
little something about this i'm going to
protect my correction officers i'm going
to protect the inmates that are serving
time and i'm not going to allow violent
people to do violence and think they can
do it without being held accountable and
we can do it in a humane fashion and if
anyone wants to talk to me about that
don't write a letter
call me and speak with me that is how
we're going to resolve this there's a
body of people that are coming into the
city council they have no desire in
moving our city forward their desire is
to be disruptive what i am going to do
i'm going to ignore them
i'm going to stay committed and
distracted and i'm going to grind if
they like it or not i'm the mayor
what a change of pace from bill de
blasio to that guy
uh unfortunately he's he's he's in the
wrong party i mean i don't know what his
other views are i assume that to get
elected
um
as a democrat
in the year 2021 i have to assume that
he's got plenty of crazy left-wing views
on on other subjects but um
he's still in the wrong party because
everything he said there was totally
rational it made complete sense
um if you have violent
people in prison who are violent within
the prison itself
then to punish them for that and also to
protect everybody else
you have to be able to segregate them
of course
but
you're trying to communicate this to
people who are
in in principle irrational
like they reject rationality in
principle
everything is emotion based
which is why
they're in favor of segregating
like non-vaccinated people who are
law-abiding as citizens
uh we could segregate them from every
aspect of society but they're not in
favor of segregating
violent rapists who are in jail and are
raping people in jail
no to segregate them within the prison
is a human rights violation
these are this is the cognitive
dissonance these these are the competing
conflicting
schizophrenic views held by people on
the left and trying to communicate them
especially if you're on their side
there's no hope
but the one thing especially that folks
on the left didn't like that he said
there
and there were chris hayes and msnbc was
taking issue with this and lots of
democrats were
but he said you know if you wear a badge
then you have the right to criticize me
on this
now
i agreed with everything he says in that
clip
i don't
i don't agree with that part
i don't think he meant it literally
but if you're an elected representative
then anybody has the right to criticize
you and um you don't have to
you know work in the government or
become a police officer to earn the
right to criticize policies that your
elected representatives you know put in
place
uh it's it's a similar thing that's when
you hear sometimes
if if there's a debate about foreign
policy and whether we should go to war
or send our troops here or there and
sometimes you hear people say well you
didn't even serve so what are you
talking about this no i don't i don't
need to
uh to
uh sign up for the military to earn the
rights
to criticize government policy that's
that's not how it works in america i
don't think he meant it literally
but that's not correct but it also is
interesting though
because what he just said there is that
not a version of trust the experts
isn't this how is that any different
from what we hear from the left all the
time about well you can't you can't
criticize fouchy if you're not a
scientist as if he is one
trust the experts
you have no experience in this
you know you're not you're not paid to
do science you're not a scientist
so isn't that basically what he just
said
he is an expert
on law enforcement
on uh you know prison policy having
worked in the field for so many years
he's an expert
but yeah they don't like it as much when
you apply it to law enforcement
trust the experts when it comes to law
enforcement issues they're not they're
not ready to do that
now you have to have a phd
in order to earn the right
to criticize dr fauci
and even if you have a phd and you
criticize them which many phds have well
then that's only evidence that you never
deserve the phd to begin with
but to even potentially have the right
you have to have a phd but to criticize
law enforcement officers uh no you don't
need to have any expense i mean you know
the person best equipped to do that is
alexandria ocasio-cortez
or someone like that
interesting how that works um so jack
basobiak shared this a few days ago it's
an article from 2019 about the woman who
created sex in the city and how she
feels now
and this is relevant again because
they've got the new sex and the city
spin-off series or whatever on hbo
and um it's ultra ultra woke obviously
but uh candace bushnell is the woman who
who created the the book that this is
based on and here's what she said in
2019. um this is from i think this is
from the daily mail
it says her best-selling book and the
racy tv series series it inspired taught
a generation of women that they could
have it all but sex and the city creator
candice buchnell 60 has admitted that
she regrets choosing a career over
having children as she is now truly
alone
um
the former sex columnist who is worth
around 18 million dollars told the
sunday times when i was in my 30s and
40s i didn't think about it then i got
divorced and when i was in my 50s i
started to see the impact of not having
children and of truly being alone i do
see that people with children have an
anchor in a way that people who have no
kids don't
so that's interesting that's what she
said in 2019.
uh jack shared this
and
then candace buchnell responded to that
a couple days ago
to jackson she said why are you
retweeting this old story as a matter of
fact i don't regret not having children
i celebrate it and i encourage other
women to do the same come see my new
show
is there still sex in the city which
just got a rave review in the new york
times
so
she expressed regret about not having
kids
and uh but now she regrets
expressing that regret and is is going
back on that because
you yeah which is which is uh
really a shame
because of course we know the truth
we know she was right before of course
you regret it
there's just no way that you could be
now in your 50s and 60s
and happy that you're alone
human beings don't work that way
being like in solitude alone
having no one in your life who
really loves you or cares about you
especially because you've divorced your
husband
so you have no spouse you have no kids
uh i don't know maybe she was like maybe
she might have siblings or something or
cousins maybe she has other family
but they're not
invested in you they they just don't
care about you in the same way that a
spouse does that your children do
and it's it's also not about it's not
just about you it's not it's not simply
that you that you don't have people
caring about you in that way it's also
that you don't have anyone to care about
in that way yourself
she was actually quite profound actually
put it in 2019 and now she's going back
on it because she's got it why why is
she going back on it because she has
another sex and the city related show
that she wants to sell
it's really pathetic on a number of
levels but what she said in 2019 was
pretty profound she says that um
that uh you know when people don't have
children don't don't have an anchor
you know it's something that anchors you
like to this world and gives you a sense
of purpose
and grounds you in a certain way
and uh you don't have that it's true
as i said you also don't have it's it's
also about having this this outlet
having people to care about to pour
yourself into
um
people to love
in in in that special way that parents
love their children and that spouses are
supposed to love each other
there's just no way that you could
get to your 60s and feel great about not
having that
and so we get these little again little
glimmers of honesty and then uh and then
but now she's saying oh oops i was
accidentally honest about that never
mind
all right the post-millennial reports
this is a lutheran pastor in chicago
offered drag prayer time for children
aaron musser who was ordained this
summer donned a blonde wig white dress
and makeup to share in worship with the
children in his parish this is saint
luke's lutheran church of logan square
and they publicized the event on
facebook they're very proud of it um
let's um
let's
take a look at some of this go ahead and
play it
so with many other exhortations
john proclaimed the good news to the
people
the gospel of the lord
you may be seated and i'd like to invite
any children or people who would like to
see
a picture book that i will be showing on
the ipad here anyone who'd like a closer
view of that to come up and sit
i have an awesome story to share with
you today i'm really excited
to share it with you i have a question
first of all have any of you ever seen a
drag queen
no no is this so this is everybody's
first time they're ever seeing a drag
queen well hello
um i am also
a boy most of the time when i'm here but
today
i
[Music]
so
the story that i want to share with you
today is called joy
okay
no surprise there female pastors of the
church they got two female pastors and a
guy in drag and um that's what's going
on with that lutheran church
um hey and what is there to criticize
it's just a grown man playing out his
sexual fantasies at church in front of a
bunch of kids
that's that's what this is by the way i
mean the drag drag and all this kind of
stuff uh
these these are men who like this is
their sexual fetish is wearing women
clothes women's clothes
um
and
if that's
your thing that you do in the privacy of
your own home
it's it's really weird
but you could do that in privacy your
own home nobody's gonna know i and and
i'm quite happy not knowing
like i have no interest i'm not going
into anyone's home
performing checks to see if they're
wearing women's clothes or not i'm not
doing that so you want to be in your
home doing that
you you can no one can stop you
but
you want to play that out in public it's
a different story and you want to
involve children
in your sexual fantasy well now that's
that's really a different story because
that's that's uh pedophilic that's child
sexual abuse you should go to prison for
it obviously
um
this would be a perfect time
i mean if there was anyone in that
church who was not a degenerate freak
lunatic
um which of course there isn't because
they wouldn't be in that church if they
if they were
but if there was just one normal person
there this would be a great time
for
to hearken back to the gospels
and uh jesus christ overturning
the tables in the temple
because as much as we're told
and for decades now we've got this false
impression of jesus as this peacenik
hippie kind of guy who's just hanging
around all the time and uh you know
non-non-aggressive telling everyone hey
chill out man
kind of like presenting jesus as if he's
like the big lebowski or something
as much as that is the impression we're
given that's actually not
the jesus that is portrayed in the
gospel
and uh that jesus
was uh
very passionate
about
of course you know especially about
protecting children
protecting vulnerable
about the truth jesus is truth
and the life um
but he but on top of that also
aggressive
at times
hostile towards
sin
hostile towards evil
and aggressive and even violent on at
least one occasion
because the turning over of the tables
in the temple was a violent act
in fact we're told in one of the stories
that he fashions a whip
it's interesting that says he fashions
it not even like he grabbed one but he
actually took a little bit of time so
there's pre-meditation here of of like
making this weapon
and using it against people
causing physical pain to them
well we can assume to be whipped
so this would have been a great time for
a little bit of a turning over the
tables in the temple approach
but unfortunately all the people there
are complicit and are also groomers of
children um so that's why that didn't
happen all right
one other story here from the guardian
that says harry potter's favorite sport
quidditch is to receive a new name in
the u.s in part because its leaders are
critical of the controversial views of
the fictional wizards creator jk rowling
which the u.s leagues have called
anti-trans
and i i only i just read this headline
and i'm reading it now for the first
time
and this only stands out to me
because yeah it's it's completely absurd
that all these harry potter fans that
are trying to excise jk rowling from her
own creation like none of this would
exist without her
but also
so there are actual people who who
play quiddich the harry potter game
how much of a dork can you possibly be
that you're not only a harry potter fan
but you you spend your free time playing
like this bunch of nerds running around
on broomsticks
and uh but they're
they have standards though you know so a
little some self-respect that's why we
can't we can't allow jk rowling to be
associated with this even though she
created all this right makes sense
before you set out to travel um for the
holidays if that's what you're doing uh
do yourself a favor and download the get
upside app because especially if you're
gonna be doing a lot of driving you can
make cash back on every gallon of gas
that you pump my listeners are making up
to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up just download
the free get upside app in the app store
or google play right now use promo code
walsh and get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's up
to 50 cents cash back that you could get
don't pay full price at the pump anymore
there's no reason to because you can get
cash back using get upside just download
the app for free and use promo code
walsh to get 50 cents a gallon cashback
on your first tank
some people who drive a lot throughout
the month are making 200 300 a month
and uh there's no catch there's no red
tape or anything like that they just
send the money right to your bank
account um or you can use paypal you can
get an e-gift card for amazon and other
brands it's as simple and easy as that
so just download the free get upside app
and use promo code walsh to get up to 50
cents a gallon cash back on your first
tank that's code walsh
okay let's get now to the comment
section
[Music]
uh so before we get to the comments i
was just giving this present from uh
from the crew sean mckenna the rest of
the uh matt walsh show teams give me
present which
i'm very
i'm
flattered i'm also slightly afraid
of what could pop out at me
so we'll see all right
i'm also very bad at receiving gifts so
now i'm doing this on camera but we'll
um
oh wow
uh
i have waited this is my nintendo 64. i
have waited
for like 20 years for this gift
hold on
this i'm actually excited about this can
i bring this on
[Music]
is this just a bit or can i actually
bring this home
you can take it home i can bring it home
okay
and mortal kombat this is from jacob the
pa who who i slaughtered in uh in the
you know the new the latest version of
mortal kombats i guess he wants to play
me again on the but i'm even better at
this because this one i know you know we
we've been doing these videos where uh
thank you so much i'm you know i am
deeply touched by this one um and we've
been oh
hopefully i don't just break it we've
been doing these videos where i play uh
where i play video games
and uh you know i'm actually not as
terrible as you might think but i've
shared the story that when i was uh that
when i was a kid like in fifth grade um
i
wanted a nintendo 64 for christmas and i
was told by my parents that you know i
was gonna get it and then i and then
christmas morning i open it up and it's
a super nintendo it's like the oh it's
the it's the the old model and then i go
to
to school the next day and like i had
already bragged to all my friends i was
getting an n64
and they said well how's that n64 and so
i lied and i lived this lie for years
where i was pretending that i had an n64
until finally you know and i i even like
they wanted to come over and play it i
had to stave them off
until finally the the whole ruse was up
and uh i've lived with that shame ever
since so now finally i have this and i'm
deeply deeply grateful for that all
right
let's get now to the comments okay
van pasterman says could getting the
omicron variant actually be good for
those who had not gotten the original
covid
in my mind if it is a lesser kova then
could it in essence be acting like a
real vaccine in that it helps you build
some immunity am i way off on this type
of thinking
no you're not way off of this thinking
at all that's
that makes a lot of sense but you're not
an expert neither am i so that's a
common sense judgment that you and i can
make but because we don't have phds
we're not allowed to make it
we have to wait for the people with the
phds to to like
seven months from now to say the thing
that we've been saying all along and
then it's valid
c-squared says i agree with matt on the
giving guys gifts thing i get my uncle
the same thing every year chocolate and
slippers the one year i decided to
change it up he was disappointed he
didn't get slippers
yeah just give him what he wants all
those so a new pair of slippers every
year
somebody's got like 50 pairs of slippers
now i'm not hitting on it i'm not
um i mean i am a little bit but we'll
move on
uh
kayla says matt i told my husband what
you said about gifts for husbands and
told him that you explained that guys
don't care about the thought behind a
gift
i then asked him what he wanted for
christmas and he responded a bunch of
thoughts
so thanks for that
i don't know if he's a dad yet but that
is he's ready to be a father i could
tell you by that uh by that dad humor
top notch top shelf
um
all right and let's go now so then some
other comments but a whole bunch of
pitbull comments as you can imagine so
we'll read a few of these this is from
erica says i was attacked by a pit bull
years ago when i was babysitting the
kids and i were outside playing and this
dog bolted from a yard across the street
and lunged at one of the kids i was
watching i was able to push her away
from the dog and then it started
attacking me a good samaritan neighbor
came over got the kids away then tried
to yank the dog off of me he was a
strong athletic young male who worked as
a firefighter and he still struggled to
get this dog off because pipples are so
strong especially while attacking
that alone should tell you that they
aren't safe i'm a small woman and i
don't know what would have happened if
he hadn't stepped in thankfully the kids
were not injured at all i needed surgery
and still deal with the injuries that i
sustained
dwight says matt regarding the pit bull
as an animal control officer everything
you said about the dog is 100 correct
this doesn't happen every year this
happens every day the media just picks
up a few here and there psa if you live
in an apartment or condo there's
absolutely zero reason for you to own a
pit bull german shepherd or husky get a
chihuahua
ethan says matt as much as i agree with
you about human lives mattering more
than animal lives you kind of just
shirked off the low number of pitbull
mullings by using emotional appeal and
graphic descriptive language the same
tactic which you discredit that people
use to try and pass draconian coveted
measures
207 years is vanishingly small you could
probably find similar numbers for far
more mundane things
blizzy says the pit bull was a rescue
dog that historically been abused and
had a history of violent behavior as a
result of the abuse that isn't evidence
of a problem with the breed but a
problem with animal abuse pit bulls are
favored among dog fighters as a result
many of them are raised in violent
abusive environments until the fighting
rings are shut down i agree with walsh
on many things but i find it a bit
disturbing how quickly walsh jumps right
on the bandwagon of wanting the
government to ban you from owning things
that he disagrees with viewing things he
disagrees with et cetera
and comparing a pit bull to a lion
please that's the exact same argument
argument the hyperventilating
hand-ringing gun grabbers use when they
compare small arms to nukes and fighter
jets
um
hendy says love your show you said 44
people died in africa but there's no
need to panic yet one young one woman
gets attacked by a dog and now i need to
put down my pitbull makes no sense
and there are different breeds of pit
bulls as well some of which are more
aggressive than others okay
so i chose the more reasonable
pro pit bull responses there were lots
of unreasonable ones one pitbull owner
actually
issued me a veiled
very thinly veiled death threat over it
and i did post a screenshot of that to
twitter so you know that i'm not i'm not
being like the squad here and making up
death threats um in any case let's just
review a few of the points here in
response to both the the reasonable and
unreasonable pitbull owners
and by the way the fact that pitbull
owners
freak out like psychotic lunatics when
you criticize pitbulls that doesn't
really dissuade me in my view about
pitbulls i have to tell you
so first of all
statistically it is a fact that pit
bulls are responsible for a hugely
disproportionate number of maulings and
killings
hugely disrespect there are hundreds of
dog breeds out there and yet well
uh way more than half of the serious
maulings and killings are done by pit
bulls
they might not bite the most and so this
is the deflection mechanism used by the
pit bull apologists they will they'll
pull up the data on dog bites and
they'll say look at that pit bulls are
way down there towards the bottom
yeah you might have smaller dogs that
will nip at your hand or whatever and
that counts as a dog bite but that's not
the point
when pit bulls bite it's a very
different story and they do a lot of
damage so the vast majority of people
killed by dogs are killed by pit bulls
that's a fact that's 100 effect
and many hundreds of people have died
that way including many children
second you don't have to tell me oh
blame the you know don't blame the dog
i don't blame the dog it's a dog i don't
blame the dog dogs are not moral animals
making moral choices
that's that's the point that's my point
i'm not mad at the dog it does what it
is bred to do what it's programmed to do
biologically
and that's why it doesn't belong in
neighborhoods and communities
i would also say that you shouldn't keep
like an elephant in your backyard if you
live in a townhouse in in in the city uh
is that because i hate elephants do i
blame ella no it's just it's just that
that wouldn't be an appropriate place to
keep an animal of that type
it's not safe for you it's not safe for
your neighbors it's not good for the
elephant
right
third um
when you hear it it's the owner's fault
not the animals okay again maybe that's
true much of the time
but that proves my point again
because these are potentially very very
dangerous animals
uniquely dangerous in ways that many
other dog breeds are not
and they require specialized care but
any old [ __ ] can buy one and uh keep
them in any kind of home or neighborhood
right
um
oh and there are plenty of good pitbull
owners that have pitbulls that freak out
because
it is ultimately an animal
and you can't really know what's going
on inside the animal's mind or what's
going to trigger it you can't actually
know that
but even if all of the the good pitbull
owners had good pit bulls the fact is
that that's just not the way it works
anyone could go and get a pimple there
there are no requirements there are no
you know there are very few laws
maybe in some communities you know they
might have rules in place but and most
do not
uh and fourth this uh this argument that
is just like guns that's absurd because
as we talked about yesterday you have a
constitutional right to bear arms it's
the second amendment there's no
constitutional right to bear pit bulls
or to bear animals okay there's not a
constitutional right to animal ownership
and um also
guns are inanimate
objects okay so there it is all about
the user
that's not the case with a dog a dog is
a is a
a creature a conscious being
that can do things and does do things on
its own you can you can exercise
influence over the creature
and that's what training is all about
and you can control them if you have
them
gated in or you have them on a leash
but that's it it's really all about
influence it's influence and deterrence
which is not the case with a gun
it's not just it's not that like a gun
won't kill anybody if you if you if you
influence it like it's this is not it's
not about influence it's about it's
fully controlled with a gun
um
and uh and then fifth the fifth point is
again you still have not explained
what pressing need or reason there is to
have pit bulls
or to breed them
or to sell them or to keep them in
communities i've explained my reason for
not
my reason is pretty simple that hundreds
of people get mauled and killed by them
including children
and
that's not good
and these dogs are disproportionately
responsible for those kinds of things so
i think those dogs shouldn't be allowed
in communities that's my reason
but what you have not explained is that
in spite of that we still need to have
dog these kind of dogs in communities
because why
i know i know you you like them you'd
prefer it but but why do we need that
what's what is the real downside to not
allowing it
that's what i don't understand
last night the daily wire premiered a
very special episode of candice candice
owens traveled to mar-a-lago for a
face-to-face interview with the former
president donald trump for an in-depth
conversation with one of the most
censored men in america um here's
candace talking about the interview
hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to a most special episode of candace
today i'm going to be sitting down and
interviewing president donald trump
just something i've noticed when he is
interviewed by anybody it's never a true
journalistic endeavor on the left when
they sit down with him they just try to
smear him live they're just looking to
write the next hit piece to pretend that
he is a horrible human being
but on the right we have the opposite
problem we fawn over him we say when are
you going to be president next we miss
you what are you coming back
neither one of these represent real
interviews and i would like to change
that today today i'm going to sit down
with him and i'm going to give him a
fair but a tough interview with
critiques that have come from his own
side
i voted for president trump make no
mistake but there are tons of questions
that need answering and i hope that i'm
able to deliver that to you all today
welcome to candace
the interview is streaming exclusively
to members at dailywire.com so head to
dailywire.com subscribe to join today
and start watching and if you want to
show your support for truth seekers like
candace head to
yesweekandis.com
to pick up some awesome candace merch
you get it that's the pun there yes we
can
the daily wires fulfilling their promise
of continuing to create new awesome
content and ben shapiro's newest show
the search is no exception the show is a
voyeuristic view of his closest and most
influential friends and him as they
share inklings and personal lives over
coffee his great friend jordan peterson
is the first to join him and it's truly
an excellent watch so if you want access
to this you got to become a member
dailywire.com subscribe
and finally as the buying administration
continues to use the pandemic to strip
americans of our freedoms the daily wire
is continuing to fight back we're
closing in on our goal of one million
signatures on our do not comply petition
and we need your help to get us across
the finish line we're just a few
thousand signatures away reaching 1
million signatures will provide a major
boost to our legal challenge we are so
close but we need your help to reach our
goal so go to dailywire.com do not
comply and get your signature on that
today now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so this is our last show before the
holiday so i wanted to do some sort of a
christmas themed cancellation this is
what i do when i'm in the holy spirit i
cancel things
and i thought about going through a list
of christmas songs that should be
canceled but i realized
there wasn't much to say it's simply a
fact that the worst christmas song of
all time the worst song of all time
period and the one that deserves to be
canceled beyond any other and the song
which it ought to be a capital crime to
play is wonderful christmas time by paul
mccartney there are of course other
christmas songs that deserve to be
recognized as the rancid ear poison that
they are felice navidad all i want for
christmas is you mary did you know to
name a few but none of them hold an
advent candle to wonderful christmas
time now i was trapped in an uber last
week um with a driver who who had the
heat turned up to 87 even though it was
like in the 70s outside and the windows
were rolled up and he was blasting
felice navidad while various foul and
ominous odors emanated from his person
and he drove in a stop and start fashion
seemingly designed to make me vomit
especially because i didn't have my
relief band with me and yet
i would prefer that whole experience
including fleece navidad to ever hearing
wonderful christmas time again
wonderful christmas time is the laziest
song ever written by any member of the
beatles which is saying something
because john lennon is responsible for
imagine
it reminds me of you know the kind of
like christmas song you might scribble
hastily onto a sheet of lined paper if
you had an assignment in sixth grade to
write a christmas song and forgot about
it until three minutes before it was due
and then you go oh shoot i forgot to
write one um okay um
simply having a wonderful christmas time
simply having a wonderful christmas time
simply having a wonderful christmas time
there you go
except if you if you handed that into
your teacher you'd get an f and she'd
send a note home to your parents
instead paul mccartney writes it and
makes a billion dollars because every
department store in the world agrees to
play that song exclusively on loop from
november 1st until mid-january
now i'm not being totally fair simply
having a wonderful christmas time aren't
the only lyrics
there are also verses like this one the
moon is right the spirit's up we're here
tonight and that's enough
i'm not sure what the moon is right even
means or why he's evoking imagery of
moons and night time for christmas
but that's downright poetic compared to
this verse
the choir of children sing their song
they practiced all year long
ding dong ding dong ding dong ding dong
ding dong ding dong ding dong ding
they practice that all year long
really
that's a shame
all in all it's an atrocious song but i
said this cancellation wasn't about the
song and yet uh and yet here i am what i
want to do instead is list what i think
of the the top two christmas movies and
then um and then two christmas movies
that that meant that many people have in
their top two but which are in fact in
reality canceled so we'll do that
starting with the cancelled christmas
movies we'll go through this quickly
first this isn't really one movie it's
like every christmas movie that has been
made at any point in the last 30 years
there has not been a great one or even a
good one
most of them have been downright
horrendous such as jim carrey's grinch
who stole christmas which qualifies as a
human rights violation i think under the
geneva convention
i tried to watch that with my kids
a couple days ago and i became very sad
and distraught as i thought about how
jesus must feel
it's his birthday and this is how we're
celebrating it
with a movie that manages to be dull and
tedious but also feel like an acid trip
at the same time
but of all the christmas movies released
during the past three decades
i think probably elf
is the top of the heap
in like the best
but that only speaks to the sad quality
of the heap
on its own there it's elf is garbage
also
it's at best a funny like five minute
skit but unfortunately the run time is
90 minutes which is basically every will
feral movie ever will feral comedies
fall into that common mold of comedy
where the story is front heavy with lots
of gags that are kind of amusing but
then in the back half they realize that
they need to have some kind of plot and
conflict and resolution so they jam all
of that in in a perfunctory fashion and
the jokes disappear and the whole thing
just sputters to a halt
so that movie is cancelled also we're
canceling home alone
now it it it has enough christmas cheer
to qualify as a good christmas movie but
i can never get past the fact that the
parents
never thought to call a neighbor and
have them come over and check on the kid
and actually even better why didn't they
call the house themselves
now i know you'll tell me and i've heard
this excuse many times
that the phone lines were down so they
couldn't call
but if that's true then answer me this
how did kevin call and order a pizza
later on in the same film
explain that to me
how did he order the pizza if the phone
lines were down
these are the kind of plot holes that
ruin a movie and i've tried to explain
this to my kids i've had this exact
argument with them
and they just they they they
you know
they can't they can't wrap their heads
around it also uh speaking of my kids
they saw home alone for the first time
three years ago and
they spent the following year randomly
booby-trapping parts of our house
to include my son once taking a nail out
of the garage and putting it sharp end
up in the middle of the kitchen floor
where i almost stepped on it and when i
yelled at him about it he told me that
he was booby-trapping it for burglars
like at home alone
and i said it's the middle of the day
and we're all home okay the chances of
maiming a member of the family instead
of a burglar are extremely high in these
circumstances
so i told him to take the nail out to
the garage which he did
but then he put it up he put it on the
floor in the garage with the sharp end
up
where i nearly stepped on it again when
i was taking the garbage out
so home alone is canceled too for that
but what are the best i don't want to
end on on just a negative note so uh
what are the best two christmas movies
of all time i think that's an easy
choice number two is a christmas story
the movie is infinitely rewatchable it's
charming it's funny the whole story
revolves around christmas
it's also appropriate for the whole
family though it isn't corny or grating
and uh so that makes it a great
christmas but it would be the best
christmas film of all time it's if not
for the lord of the rings the fellowship
of the rings
specifically the first one which is the
number one christmas movie ever made
you know every year there's this cliched
and boring discourse around the question
of whether or not die hard is a
christmas movie it is
but what we should be talking about is
the fact that lord of the rings is a
christmas movie
how do i know this well for one i feel
it in my bones it's part of my lived
experience two the fellowship starts its
quest to destroy the ring on december
25th that's a fact go watch the movie
again three there are elves
they don't make toys but they have
pointy ears four one of the main
protagonists is a magical old man with a
white beard five snow is prominently
featured in no less than three scenes of
the film so we have elves a guy in white
beard snow and december 25th
so it's a christmas movie through and
through a folks
and the best one of all time in fact
so lord of the rings is not canceled but
elf home alone and uh wonderful
christmas time are
there you go
this may not have been the most
important daily cancellation i've ever
done but that's what you're getting
because it's my last show before the
break
take what you get and be grateful
beggars can't be choosers even on
christmas
and we'll leave it there merry christmas
uh have a great holiday see you on the
other side godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
vadowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters the matte
wall show is a daily wire production
copyright dailywire 2021.
john vickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia howe for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire